we are begging the worst people on the
planet the taliban to at least give us
the optical grace of not burning down
our embassy that's gonna work guys way
to man up there if you could just not
burn our embassies there aren't these
ugly pictures on cnn and they get people
mad at us that would be amazing
pathetic this is all it's amazing to
watch this administration spin as though
they're just not abandoning these folks
and again you want to abandon them make
the case make the case why they should
be abandoned make the case why the
sacrifice that we are currently
undergoing not the sacrifice we
underwent for the last 20 years the
sacrifice we are currently undergoing
is unnecessary
i haven't heard virtually anybody make
that case i keep hearing phrases like
endless wars thrown around without
recognition of the fact that we had 3
500 troops on the ground and zero combat
deaths in the last 18 months
i i keep hearing phraseology thrown
around about look how much money we've
already spent which is sort of like
saying you buy a house and let's say the
house is a money pet like it's a
complete money pit and you spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
upgrade this house and it's eaten up
your savings
so after you're done right and now
you're living in the house it's got some
maintenance issues but you know you're
living there and you've already spent a
lot of so you decide you know what
because i spent a lot of money here over
the last 10 years i'm out now it just
abandons in the house that makes no
sense why would you do that again the
question is not what we've spent in the
past or whether that's justified there
are serious questions about that the
question is why are we leaving now and
the answer is because joe biden is a
boob a rube and a that is the
answer there's no other answer that is
possible
you know that he's gone completely wrong
when even the washington post editorial
board is like guys this dude is screwing
things up in a radical way the
washington post their editorial board
they uh they put up a peace title the
afghan lives ruined or lost will be part
of biden's legacy yeah no no bleep
according to the washington post
editorial board mr biden called it quits
he says because after 20 years of trying
to get kabul to govern effectively and
fight harder against the taliban there
was still no outright victory or
prospect of one but the united states
was stalemated not defeated there's a
difference and how big a difference may
soon become tragically apparent in
addition to preventing terrorists from
using afghanistan as a base for another
911 the united states achieved or at
least oversaw real progress for the
people of afghanistan when the taliban
ruled between 1996 and 2001 it forbade
schooling for girls by 2015 the last
year for which world bank data exist
more than 50 percent of girls attended
first grade in 2006 they call it
american university of afghanistan which
now enrolls over 1700 students open in
kabul supported by u.s government funds
it has partnerships with stanford the
uc's university of california and the
university of nebraska a massive
terrorist attack in 2016 forced the auaf
to close it courageously reopened in
2017. most afghans live in unfathomable
in unfathomable poverty but today's per
capita income of around 550 bucks per
year is still a 66 improvement in real
terms since 2002.
biden surveys the impending disaster and
absolve himself of any responsibility he
says it's up to afghan leaders to come
together he said they've got to fight
for themselves the truth is they had
been fighting but the united states had
trained them to do it with the support
of u.s advisors and contractors suddenly
all the support is just gone
the biden administration says it will
take care of people who work directly
for the united states
in a real sense though this country
assumed at least a partial
responsibility for the afghan people and
now we are abandoning them of course
that is very largely true and you know
the video coming out from afghanistan is
not pretty the bbc has a report about
what life is like under restored taliban
rule suffice it to say it doesn't look
like people living in brooklyn
the market is still busy
women have apparently been allowed to
come here without male companions if
they need to
but elsewhere taliban commanders have
reportedly banned them
they don't wear the burka there is no
problem they can wear the hijab yeah
the next day a young woman was killed
close by allegedly for wearing immodest
clothing many fear the taliban want to
resurrect their practice of brutal
punishments
they insist they were not responsible
for this flogging supposedly filmed last
year many people here in afghanistan and
around the world
would be
horrified at the idea of a society where
hands are cut women are stoned to death
it says we're bringing this judge is it
better to let these crimes go on
punishment
you mean the crime of like walking
around
without your head covered in a bag like
that that crime right there
yeah things are things are going
beautifully over there by the way how
pathetic is america right now here's how
pathetic america is this story is unreal
okay this is from the new york times the
u.s asks taliban to spare its embassy in
coming fight for kabul
we are basically as we are begging the
worst people on the planet the taliban
to at least give us the optical grace of
not burning down our embassy you know
it's okay if you take over the country
and you kill all of the people who
worked with us and you acid all the
women who go to school and you beat
people in the street and sometimes shoot
them in the street that's all okay
please if you could just not burn our
embassy so there aren't these ugly
pictures on cnn and they get people mad
at us that would be amazing
pathetic with a capital p according to
the new york times american negotiators
are trying to extract assurances from
the taliban that they will not attack
the us embassy in kabul if the extremist
group takes over the country's
government and ever wants to receive
foreign aid three american officials
said foreign aid the if you talk it to
the taliban
do you
what
don't burn our capital if you ever want
us to sign you a check
under what circumstances would we be
signing checks to the taliban
the people who literally are murdering
all of the people we allied ourselves
with
this is i mean this is legitimately one
of the most pathetic things i've ever
heard in terms of american foreign
policy we are now begging the taliban a
ragtag group of eighth century
primitives we are begging them to not
burn our capital
to not burn our embassy because if they
burn our embassy maybe we won't sign
them a welfare check
according to the new york times the
effort led by zalmai khalilzad the chief
american envoy and talks with the
taliban seeks to stave off a full
evacuation of the embassy as they
rapidly see cities across afghanistan on
thursday the state department announced
it was sending home an unspecified
number of the 1400 american station at
the embassy and drawing down is what the
agency's spokesperson ned price
described as a core diplomatic presence
in kabul
by the way the the pentagon spokesperson
announcing this thing i mean this is
just it's pathetic it's pathetic
pathetic footage
and i will say that america's response
to all of this to to the insanity of
what's going on
is even more pathetic the us embassy put
out a statement about the
the detention by the taliban of members
of the afghan government here is the
statement put out by the embassy of the
united states of america the most
powerful country in the history of the
world again to a bunch of ragtag cavemen
from the 8th century quote the us
embassy in afghanistan condemns
detention of afghan officials we
strongly condemn the unlawful arrest of
several members of the afghan government
including both civilian leaders and
officers of the afghan national defense
and security forces credible sources
indicate that the taliban have detained
provincial government officials and
members of the afghan police in several
locations these actions are unacceptable
and they contradict the taliban's claim
to support a negotiated settlement in
the ongoing doha peace process the
actions also contrast the taliban's own
rhetoric providing for the safety of
afghan leaders and troops in areas
recently seized by the taliban we're
urging the immediate release of all
afghan government officials detained by
the taliban and we are calling on the
taliban to fully and earnestly engage in
negotiations that end the suffering of
the afghan people and pave the way for
an inclusive political settlement that
benefits all afghans that's going to
work guys
way to man up there that's totally going
to work
hey
you mean a weakly and vaguely worded
you're urging the taliban to not execute
the people they oppose well then i mean
that that radically ch until then the
taliban were just like we're gonna do
whatever the hell we want and execute
all of our enemies but now that you put
out a statement urging them not to do so
for the sake of miss congeniality-esque
world peace that's going to change the
math on the ground
nobody ever asked them to be nice before
now that somebody's asked them to be
nice i think that'll change everything
that
again there are no words for how
pathetic this is and remember the people
who are currently dancing in the offices
of the governor of akashi not only lack
rhythm they lack a basic sense of
civilization and human decency these are
the worst people on earth there's some
video that emerged from afghanistan of
taliban fighters dancing around
honestly they have even worse rhythm
than i do which is saying an awful lot
here here's some of that footage
apparently good at humiliating the biden
state department very bad at dancing
also that's that music is not okay
that's enough of that okay meanwhile by
the way the vacuum is being filled
remember afghanistan is not the only
country on the planet and the taliban
are the only group we have to worry
about china is now preparing to
recognize the taliban because china is
completely transactional china is
entirely transactional understand that
us abandoning afghanistan does not mean
that some group will never hear of again
is going to take over it means that the
chinese government will cut a deal with
the taliban to extract natural resources
the chinese government will strengthen
itself if you think of china as a
serious long-term threat to the
viability of the american project which
you should because they're incredibly
aggressive then it should trouble you
that china has now extended its
tentacles ever more westward
according to u.s news china is now
preparing to recognize the taliban as
the legitimate ruler of afghanistan if
it succeeds in toppling the
western-backed government in kabul the
u.s news has learned a prospect that
undercuts the biden administration's
remaining source of leverage over the
insurgent network as it continues its
startling campaign to regain
control beijing has publicly pressured
the taliban to continue working toward a
peace agreement an outcome china appears
to genuinely prefer and won the u.s is
pressed with growing urgency but new
chinese military and intelligence
assessments of the realities on the
ground have prompted leaders in the
chinese communist party to prepare to
formalize their relationship with the
insurgent network according to multiple
us and foreign intelligence sources
familiar with the chinese assessments so
while the biden administration's like
guys please don't burn our embassy
because we might not send you foreign
china's like if you burn their embassy
you're still gonna get foreign aid guys
we're gonna be your friends
okay china does not care with whom they
make a deal they don't care about the
human rights of the people whom they
make a deal because they're a human
rights violator themselves they are a
tyrannical overlordship
they are a real threat to american
interest globally
isolationism is not a solution to your
opponents wanting to expand their power
if the taliban want to claim an
international legitimacy these actions
will not get them legitimacy they seek
said white house spokeswoman shinsaki
they should devote the same energy to
the peace process as they do to the
military campaign or alternatively they
could ignore you and then just make a
deal with the chinese
so all of this is going extremely
extremely well this is a massive failure
on the part of the binding
administration and they need to own it
they need to own it in the same way the
barack obama had to own the rise of isis
this is way worse this is way worse at
least you can make an argument with
regard to isis that isis was a small
ragtag ban when we pulled out of iraq
this is significantly worse we all know
what's happening in real time this is
not like we leave and then isis
gradually rises and suddenly six months
later we're worried about it we're
watching the bad guys take over kabul
now
and biden is like well you know
matlock's on
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment